okay hello and welcome to my talk about
prediction of status changes in software
tests my name as I was already
introduced as Christopher vana
I'm a IT consultant and just started
working in Hamburg I moved here a month
ago but David brought me here and said
there's a PI data meet up come here
cool people lots of cool talks and I
thought yeah I have something that I can
talk to talk about as well so the agenda
for this short little talk I'm gonna
give you a short introduction on what I
was doing and why I was doing it and
what was the purpose afterwards how did
we even predict status changes and what
are these status changes in general and
the training of the models is the point
afterwards and then of course I will
show your result and try to give you the
best I could do my work and last but not
least a use case use case and an Outlook
on way could maybe apply what I was
working on so in the introduction
developed software of course needs tests
because otherwise you couldn't ensure
the functionality of the already written
code and what you wanted the code to
behave like and what you wanted it to do
so you will test suits to ensure those
functionalities and further time those
test suits will grow larger and larger
and will be executed on a cyclic basis
so let's say once a month all the test
cases inside your test suit will be
executed and you will get results for
your tests but projects will get bigger
over time
thus your test suit will grow as well
and the time which is consumed by the
test suit execution will grow as well as
the resources used for it
so we tried to formalize those cyclic
executions into something called status
and the status can be transitioned so
you have a test case and on the first
time you execute the test case the test
case has passed and on the next time it
says failed so you get a transition and
this is the status change of the test
cases the transitions equals our labels
which I was trying to try my networks
for so how did I predict the status
changes first of all that's a question
why would I predict those transitions
because I mean I could just try to
predict the test case outcomes and would
be good to go but I said I wanted to to
get sorry I wanted to get more than just
one information because if I execute a
single test case I only have looked at
this certain point of history of the
execution of the test case and the more
test cases I execute the more I get data
and thus two states
so two test cases executed means more
input information and thus better
learning of course
and the transition occurrence means that
I get a better knowledge of what is
happening and later on I will show you
why it is better applicable sorry I need
to drink something okay so now we have
the transitions kind of formed and know
what these transitions are how can we
predict them we want to weigh up
different architectures so same thing
thinking about which was the best
network I could use I was thinking
different approaches like MLPs and
recurrent neural networks and
convolutional neural networks all those
things were weighed in before I started
to work on them and there were some
different approaches like a certain form
of convolution neural network that could
be in a timely manner managed and thus
my my status changes could be listed
over time and there was a certain one
dimensional convolutional neural network
that maybe would fit to this point but I
had to but I would have to pre-process
the data in a very certain way so that
this would work so I was keeping it in
the back of my head for maybe later use
but I decided to go with an MLP
approach and I was trying out different
input groups and the project I was
working on there were data gathered over
the course of four years and it's all
state over for example the source
version I use a hash who was working on
the time of the commit very very simple
things like component names file names
that were touched with in the the commit
but other things like the future
creation was manually done by another
person working on this project so I had
to input groups the one which I called
raw data because they were untouched
they were just given into the system and
I was giving them into a model to train
and the other person working on the
matter
used common machine learning approaches
like random forests and thus had to
prepare the input data and I mean it was
already given so I was testing both
groups
and I was testing a third group the
composition of both groups and
afterwards I wait up what would please
produce in the best result on the input
groups I did use binary cross entropy
loss wait I mean this is a multi-class
problem why would I use binary cross
entropy loss well I made a mistake there
but it still worked because if we are
going into the chaos framework it tells
us that the binary cross entropy
function is mint over the sum of the
logit we are getting and thus it still
worked but I mean how could I mean
something there was just should consist
of two inputs okay and if we go deeper
we are going to the ground of the binary
cross entropy function which was then
kind of similarly put up like the
categorical cross entropy function to be
honest the differences were very
slightly and was four month ago they
were just very similar to each other and
the mean fixed it so it just could roll
with the binary cross and for pillows
although I had a multi-class problem and
the results shown here
I know this is a very colorful graph at
the first moment on this graph you can
see four different kind of approaches
you can see the categorical accuracy for
the validation and the test data set and
binary accuracy for the validation and
the test data set and I will try to show
you this I made it up different
transition sizes ranged between one
10,000 and 50,000 transitions and try to
[Music]
compare the results I got and the for
example the blue and the orange ones are
the categorical accuracy for the
categorical loss the categorical cross
entropy loss of course and the green and
the red ones are found the binary cross
entropy loss and as you can see here in
the on the first transition step the
binary cross entropy loss was performing
a bit worse then they need each other
and afterwards the binary cross entropy
loss as a loss function from a neural
network worked way better than the
categorical cross entropy pills surely
you could maybe explain it with the
quality of the data but my opinion this
curve was kind of outstanding and saying
binary losses may be better of course
later on I took some more tests but this
was just an outline of what happened
there so why is that
I mean binary cross entropy loss I
already told you should not work but it
did work so we've seen that Kerris is
using a specific way of implementing
this loss function and thus it generally
works and doesn't throw me an error on
starting the training and we would need
a specific performance metric afterwards
that just needs to be set because if I
use binary course across entropy loss as
my loss metric I will receive the binary
accuracy afterwards so oh sorry
I didn't want to point you so you've got
to take this into account if you want to
compare the binary cross at the binary
accuracies on your resulting model
because I had 13 different transitions
so 13 different labels
and 11 out of those what because I used
softmax function as an output layer 11
of those would always be guessed right
because they can only be one true gas
and the others will be false so 11 of
them would always be right and thus it
makes it a 85% ground truth I call it or
you just use the categorical accuracy
for better comparison so how did I train
the model I mean I wanted to get the
best model but we all know this is deep
learning or they have deep learning in
general so best model isn't working but
I wanted to get a good model and for
this I use something called the hyper
Bend framework which is a kind of new
approach I think it's one year old and
it's a bended like problem solving for
getting a good configuration on your
networks because usually you have a
problem and you want to solve it be a
training a network for this
classification task but you don't know
how to set your parameters like the
batch size or which you know which
initializer you want to have or how many
and which activation functions drop out
layers better on there are just so many
hyper parameters and you can't cover
them all and try to get every
configuration to run so you can just
rely on the hyper band framework and
define your own hyper parameter spaces
so AG this is a a real line taken out of
the hyper band framework and then this
framework there you can for example set
the batch size is in the range 16 to 128
or you can give it certain numbers and
afterwards the framework is just running
random configurations which are drawn
from these spaces
and for each configuration one random
draw for every choice is taken and then
it's survival of the fittest so Darwin
already said it is not the strongest of
the species that survivors no the most
intelligent but the one most responsive
to change so what is most responsive to
those changes you can decline a declare
different different ways of what is the
most responsive to change in your
opinion for mine it was the loss I
wanted to get the loss as low as
possible which is my opinion the common
way to train networks but everyone's on
its own and then there are eighty-one
different configurations drawn from your
hyper parameters base and each are given
one iteration to train on and afterwards
it's really survival of the fittest all
out of those eighty-one different
configurations 27 best are taken and
given further more three iterations and
this goes on and on and on until you get
one configuration which is pretty good
and this is a sample output of the hyper
band I mean yeah it's very small it's
just for having seen one so if hyper
band finish it finishes it's it's a
execution you get five of these outputs
on your console and there as well
printed to some file but you can work
with these five best performing
configurations and for my final result I
only took the really best performing
because because it was I think 0.5 has
lost value even better than the other
ones so I took a really good two on this
and the final result consisted of the
model training setup which was built
over the course by the best config
gotten from the hyper band the fixed
transition size of 50k the binary cross
entropy loss is very only song and I
wanted to get both metrics the binary
and the categorical accuracy as a
performance metric this is the diagram
shown for the best performing result I
got and it says that sorry it's very
small and that with a 81% accuracy on
the validation data set I could predict
the status change that will happen on
the given input data which makes it four
out of five
transitions could be identified and
predicted right for the future and thus
a developer could be warned and five out
of four out of five times if his commit
might be for example risky or something
might break some code might end in an
error loop some anything so what is the
use case of the sole and the outlook
then developer wants Computers changes
and a plug-in takes the input data like
the source control and who is committing
and what's the time he's committing
right now by the way Fridays evening's
is not a good commit time just saying
afterwards the transitions are predicted
and all associated test case are given a
status change that might happen and the
developer gets warmed wand on risky
commits and as I mentioned earlier in
the beginning of the talk there's a case
in which I want to only consider the
transitions because
my toe cure that my train network is
telling me the transition will be arrow
to past but the current status of the
test case is let's say failed so that
won't even work out also i've minimized
additional wrong input-output mappings
and even thinned the shell and the
chance is not having a correct
predictive and additionally there was a
defect database in the back which was
helping and trying to find solutions on
the fly based on the test cases if they
were running wrong and this speed up the
whole committing and trying to fix your
errors process a lot and saved a lot of
computation time that's it from my side
I hope you enjoyed the talk
[Applause]